so it's just fascism also  fascism  so called national socialism it's also a  kind of social yeah but i bet there was  no it wasn't public owners there was  public direction so the state would tell  factories what to do with a still  private profit and a large part of why  the nazis succeeded was the extent to  which they managed to co-opt major  manufacturers in germany  uh so  it's you know direction versus ownership  it's a dictatorial i mean that's a very  particular implementation yeah so you  have to you have to consider the full  details of the implementation but it's  basically  dictator guided yeah  if you want to if you want to check this  owned if you want to take a a proper  vision then you have to say it's the  ownership of the means of production by  the state yeah okay versus the ownership  by private that rules out the nazi  period  do you use the word that again they're  bastardizing as much as americans do  in the opposite direction  you